hi welcome to another cold fusion via in
last week's episode we saw the
mechanisms for how Co vat19 works what
makes it dangerous the potential
treatments on the horizon before ending
on how the world is coming together at
this time if you haven't seen that
episode you should definitely watch it
first it's important information in
today's episode we'll see how people are
coming together in using technology to
fight this pandemic from artificial
intelligence to sterilizing robots to
rapid development of new technologies
being reappropriation in ways we've
never seen before
usually emerging technologies are held
back by infrastructure financing and
bureaucratic constraints with the
challenge of covert 19 we can put these
new technologies to the test
[Music]
obviously robots aren't susceptible to
the virus so they're being deployed to
carry out many tasks such as cleaning
and sterilizing and also delivering food
and medicine this is all in an effort to
reduce human to human contact
Purdue technology he produced catering
robots have sent fleets of their robots
to hospitals and hotels around China the
robots help serve food to those infected
or in quarantine limiting human
interaction uvd robots from the company
blue ocean robotics uses ultraviolet
light to autonomously kill viruses
curbing the potential spread to other
humans the startup have already sold
robots to over 40 countries closer
azúcar CEO of the company explains our
robot uses advanced algorithms and
spatial sensors to cover all surfaces
with the right amount of virus killing
light with our data users can see
exactly which rooms have been cleared
for which bacteria and viruses according
to the company it takes between 10 to 15
minutes to disinfect a room can it
effectively kill the corona virus on
surfaces yes definitely virus like
Corona has been a you know deactivated
by more than 99.999% Hong Kong's mass
transit railway is now employing
vaporized hydrogen peroxide robots to
disinfect their trains the transit
railway services millions of passengers
each day and has become a breeding
ground for the virus these newly
purchased deep cleaning robots will be
able to reach places difficult to get to
you by hand they're also going to be
deployed to the locations where covert
19 patients have been they then will
disinfect the area making it safe for
him an entry before this virus attack we
have already demonstrated and proof this
robot robot with h2o 2 hydrogen peroxide
in a mist form at the concentration of
150 ppm explos it with 15 minutes of
time you were able to kill the virus and
all different kind of gem Hong Kong is
also in the process of testing nano air
filtration this is to improve the air
quality in trains and curb the virus
spreading through the air
speaking of air quality we should talk
about the most low-tech solution of all
[Music]
researchers at Cambridge University
tested a wide range of household
materials for use in homemade masks to
measure effectiveness
they shot bacteria and virus spores in
two different materials and measured the
results as it turned out vacuum cleaner
bags are 95% effective and a dish towel
is 83 percent effective masks also
reduce the potential spread of the a
symptomatically infected he is a video
representing that on the left is an
uncovered mouth and on the right is one
with a mask
[Music]
recent research on MIT and Stanford has
shown that when we speak little saliva
micro droplets come flying out of our
mouth six feet or more those droplets if
you're infected contains millions of
particles of the virus if I'm not
wearing a mask I'm putting my community
at risk and that just feels like an
awful thing to do of course it should be
stressed that people shouldn't go out
and hoard masks taking them away from
medical professionals this is a great
example of what can happen when smart
technically oriented people come
together in a time of need
ventilators have become essential in the
battle against covert 19 but health
systems around the world are facing
shortages to address this problem
engineers around the world have set up
Network communication platforms using
technology like telegram and even
Facebook here they share information
about open source designs for
manufacturing ventilators with 3d
printers anyone with a 3d printer can
collaborate by printing the necessary
respirator components the goal is to
make them available to healthcare
services in just a few days a group in
Spain were able to build an open-source
respirator prototype another Irish
open-source Hardware project has
produced a prototype ventilator using 3d
printed parts and readily available
inexpensive materials after the project
was spun up on Facebook the design was
completed in seven days and attracted
the participation of over 300 engineers
medical professionals and researchers I
think that's pretty cool to add to this
companies such as Tesla Ford and General
Motors are all pitching in to make
ventilators
the detection of an outbreak and the
issuance of public warnings are critical
during pandemics blue dot a Canadian
start-up developed an AI which analyzes
news and government reports as well as
social media in order to track
infectious diseases it ended up issuing
a warning before the CDC or the World
Health Organization unfortunately not
many people listened to these warnings
understanding what contextual factors
make a disease essentially turn into an
outbreak and so this means that you need
to look at everything from you know
global air travel data but also
population data climate mosquito data
demographic data and as well as a
country's ability to respond to an
outbreak so once you combine and layer
all those data and those modeling
techniques you can really understand
where disease will spread to and what
the impact will be where the speed and
accuracy of diagnosis can mean life or
death Jack Maas Alibaba is coming to the
rescue
the e-commerce giant has developed an AI
diagnosis system which processes CT
scans with 96% accuracy now over a
hundred clinics are using it the tool
can do in 20 seconds what it takes a
human about 15 minutes this is because
there's hundreds of images to evaluate
Iran and many other countries are using
AI image recognition to diagnose CT
scans google's deepmind unit recently
used their AI computing power to study
public databases to guess the structural
proteins that likely make up the corona
virus the company then released its
findings in an effort to help
researchers work towards a cure
in the same vein an open source hardware
called fold at home is utilizing the
power of over 700,000 home gaming pcs to
calculate and understand exactly how the
virus works for the basis of future
drugs the PCs are run by everyday gamers
and all communicate over a network
the combined power of the system is now
over 1.5 million trillion operations per
second Reza is a smartphone based acute
respiratory disease diagnostic tests
they uses machine learning algorithms to
analyze a patient's cough sound to treat
diseases such as pneumonia and asthma
they're hoping to use the system in the
battle against covert 19 among other
things the United States government has
unveiled a portal containing over 29,000
research papers already conducted on the
corona virus in a joint effort with
Silicon Valley the tech giants are using
their AI tools to crawl through these
papers providing new insights about the
discoveries of thousands of independent
researchers understanding how this new
virus behaves is critical for defining
measures that can stop its spread next a
strain is an open-source project that
provides data sequencing and
visualizations showing how the virus is
evolving and if there are any possible
mutations that can change its nature
it's largely understood that the virus
hasn't become more dangerous over time
as it's spread this data goes against
the theory of a more deadly strain known
as the L strain that causes more deaths
[Music]
Israel is planning to repurpose this
anti-terrorism technology in order to
track the spread of the virus
this is pending cabinet approval the
technology would track the phones of the
infected allowing for the government to
track their GPS location they would know
exactly who they've come into contact
with and where they've been the United
States government is also engaging in
talks at Facebook Google and other tech
companies to potentially bring about a
similar system in the u.s. in Europe the
general data protection regulation or
gdpr forbids the tracking of people's
movements and contacts using smartphone
location data without consent in asia
things are a little different
Singapore's personal data protection
Commission has allowed the collection
use and disclosure of personal data
without a person's consent they say it's
to carry out contact tracing and other
coronavirus response measures Vietnam is
tracking locals and foreigners through
mobile apps while Thai immigration
authorities are using location data to
track those arriving in the country call
it what you want but this is definitely
mass surveillance and definitely poses a
serious risk to privacy it's a fine
balance you can slow the virus to spread
dramatically with accurate and more
detailed data than you could have
otherwise or it could very easily turn
into a backdoor to spy on your
population the main problem is when this
is all over
will governments give back their powers
the answer is probably no but then again
don't all of our governments spy on us
anyway
it really is an interesting dilemma
privacy what is it something that kind
of goes out the window when you're in a
situation where you're facing a mortal
danger as we are with this kovat 19
pandemic definitely just like terrorism
it's always during crises that you have
a shift in acceptance and the way the
government is going to control a little
more of what used to be public freedom
before all those ads going to be thrown
away in five or six months that's a
very very different situation and this
is something we have to ask yourself and
ask our government right now because the
decision we're going to take about those
apps today will change an effect in a
very hard way or society in many
countries researches and scientists have
been scrambling to create rapid testing
15-minute tests are starting to appear
around the world and antibody tests are
on the horizon the latter is going to
allow for communities to know who has
already had the virus
as most of the world has begun their
lockdown stage video calls are keeping
people together they've become essential
tools for dealing with confinement one
of the prominent applications is zoo
which according to the New York Times
received approximately 600,000 downloads
in one day at the beginning of the
pandemic despite reports of privacy
concerns the application is being used
to organize team meetings or to help
loved ones stay in touch with one
another and even for school classes the
last few weeks have borne witness to an
unleashing of creativity users have
organized concerts workshops virtual
get-togethers birthday parties and even
weddings but out of this use has spawned
the phenomena of zoom Bobby zoom bombing
is where a person barges into a school
class or business meeting only to
display the most inappropriate imagery
imaginable while it may range from
mildly amusing to funny to truly
disappointing really it's just trolls
trying to find a new way to amuse
themselves in the age of covert 19
while this outbreak is something to take
seriously it's not unbeatable
humanity has persevered through
difficult times the way some countries
are working together to stop this
pandemic is uplifting to see scientists
and researchers no longer have
geographical boundaries and the world is
starting to put all of this recent
technology to very good use so in
finishing remember to take care of
yourself practice social distancing and
wash your hands of course and hopefully
at the end of all of this we can become
better prepared for the future we can
use this crisis as a lesson to learn how
to better organize our supply chains
global communications health management
systems and also gain a new respect for
those essential to our society so that's
about it if you haven't watched my
previous video on this topic it's highly
recommended that you do I'll leave a
link for it below anyway thanks for
watching my name is Dakota and you've
been watching cold fusion I'll see you
again soon for the next episode cheers
guys stay safe
cold fusion are you thinking
[Music]
you